okay today I'm going to talk to you
about quadrats what quadrat is is it's a
square frame enclosing a known area so
for example a lot of quadrats are one
meter squared now what a quadrat could
be useful is they could be used to help
estimate the number of organisms in a
particular area and I'm going to show
you how to do that so what I've drawn
here at the bottom what this represents
is it's a bird's eye view of a field
containing lots and lots of plants
called poppies um now if this was a real
field obviously it would be nearly
impossible to count each poppy
individually to figure out how many
poppies are in the whole field so what
we can do is we can use a quadrat to
help estimate how to do that so the
first thing you do and this is the
really important word that we always
need to think about when we think about
quadrats is we randomly place the
quadrat down so we randomly do this so
let's say it randomly falls here so this
here just represents the quadrat that
I've put it down okay now if I put the
quadrat down we should see that there'd
be lots of poppies underneath the
quadrat in the holes of the Quadra so
the quadrat just allows it to be nice
and easy to count those poppy so one two
three four five six seven eight nine ten
eleven twelve thirteen fourteen fifty
sixty seven eight nine twenty one two
three four - five - six - seven - eight
- nine thirty so because of the squares
it just makes it easy to count the
number of poppies within that particular
quadrat so the next step will be this
you're after you've randomly placed the
quadrat then you count the organisms now
quadrats are usually used to count
plants but they can be used to count
other things such as slugs or other
other maybe insects that are less mobile
if it's a butterfly think it wouldn't be
as good because the butterflies could
just fly away so they use the counting
organisms now what you need to do next
obviously
this one space in the field isn't
necessarily representative of the whole
of the field for example you can see
there's a high density of poppies here
so as a result we need to repeat process
for a total of 10 times so we randomly
going to place the quadrat nine more
times across the field so let's say this
one there so it's 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 so
as a result we're getting a kind of
we're getting a view of the poppy
distribution across the whole of the
field rather than just one particular
section so what we do next is we find
the total number of poppies so let's
imagine the total number of poppies that
we counted in our quadrat is 200 poppies
now our next step is we want to find the
mean number of poppies so the average
number per quadrat now to do that in
this particular example we'd have to do
200 because that's how many poppies
they're wearing total divided by the
number of quadrats so in this particular
example it would be 200 divided by 10
which would be 20 poppies now the next
step is what we have to do is obviously
we need to find the area of the whole
field so we'd have to measure the length
of this side the field let's say that's
50 meters in length and we'd have to
measure the length of this side of the
field let's say that's 40 meters in
length right there so the next step is
to find the total area of the whole
field so the total area of the field is
going to be 50 times 40 which equals
2,000 meters squared right we've just
got one more step to do we know that the
average number of poppies per
meter squared is 20 so in 2,000 meters
squared all we're going to have to do is
20 poppy's times 2,000 because that's
how many meter squares we've got
effectively so the answer is 40,000
Papi's is a estimate of how many Papi's
are in the whole field so just to
quickly remind you a quadrat is just a
square frame to help us count organisms
it could be used if we place it randomly
across an area of a field ten times it
can help us estimate the number of
organisms in the entire field you count
the organisms you find the total you
then find the mean per quadrat then what
you need to do is times it by the area
of the whole field and we should have an
estimate of how many poppies are in the
whole field without having to count each
one individually thank you